let me ask about on the one particular
technology that i've been
uh learning a lot about thinking a lot
about talking about
which is bitcoin or cryptocurrency in
general but bitcoin specifically
which a lot of people argue that the
bitcoin that uh
setting ideas aside when you look at
practical tools that governments use to
manipulate its people is
inflation of the monetary within the
monetary system and so
they see bitcoin as a way for the
for individuals to fight that to go
outside those
specific government control systems and
thereby
sort of decentralizing power you know
there's a case to be made historically
of the 20th century that you
you couldn't have stalin you couldn't
have hitler you couldn't had much of the
evil that you see in the
world if they couldn't control the
monetary system you couldn't have had
the new deal
and fdr realized this very quickly right
we confiscated all the gold
everybody knows fdr is going to come
into into to become president
of confiscate the gold so one of the one
of the mythologies
the myths about the great depression is
the
that there were all these bank runs that
well bank runs happened because
everybody was afraid that fdr would get
elected confiscate the gold so everybody
ran to the bank and took the gold
little did they realize that he would
confiscate their private holdings
in their own backyards he would dig he
would force them to dig up the girls
from their own backyard
but yes one of the first things fdr did
in spite of denying it throughout the
campaign
right he he was asked about this over
and over again and denied it
one of the first things was was take
over the gold and take the united states
the federal reserve off the gold
standard
so that they can in a sense print money
and that he could start spending
um yeah what people don't realize just
to clarify your own set is fdr
this is something that's so crazy to us
that we think okay i'm misunderstanding
it
fdr made it illegal for people to own
gold unless it's like a wedding ring
and before that contracts
because inflation was a concern i make a
contract with your
own right i said okay you're either
going to pay me in
fifteen hundred dollars for my work or
the gold equivalent because
if that fifteen hundred dollars you know
you know weimar germany and you have
hyperinflation
i don't want that 1500 just give me the
gold bullion and fdr said
all of those clauses he broke every
contract
they don't they don't matter so now if i
say iran says okay you owe me
three feet of drywall and i go here's
three feet of drywall
it's uh 12 inches and you go wait three
feet is 36 and she's going no not
anymore
what am i supposed to do and because you
have when you print more money
the value of every individual dollar
matters less
it becomes that much harder to plan
anything either in the government level
or in the private level because if i'm
managing outlays if i'm trying to pay my
workers i'm trying to build factories
i'm thinking long term
and i don't know what this dollar is
going to buy in 10 years
that puts an enormous incentive for me
to spend it now and not
save it because if i save it it's gonna
be worth a lot less
and the worst thing about inflation and
this is something i think people who are
pro-capitalism don't talk about enough
they do talk about i would just like to
see it more this by far
hurts the poor the poorest of the poor
the most
when we came to this country my mom told
me they would go to 86th street in
bensonhurst with the fruit stands to buy
mikuchika
some grapes and you go to this fruit
stand and she'd walk all the way to the
other corner
and if it was three cents more a pound
or less a pound she'd walk all the way
back
because that three cents mattered now if
i have this dollar
and it's five percent inflation whatever
and next year it's 95 cents
me and you the three of us might not
care but if i'm destitute hand to mouth
and i've got five percent less that is
really
a material consequence of my life so
inflation
really is evil because it hurts the
people for who those pennies matter
well one of the ways the government gets
around that and it's because they get
they get smart to that right
is they index everything right so they
they index your social security they
index welfare
they try to make sure but that only
makes you more dependent on them
and and the people in the modern context
that saving hurts the most the
inflation hurts the most the saviors
people trying to save money and
and fed policy right now is just
horrific if you're a savior right
because
the fed is it the interest rates are
zero you get nothing on your saving
and cost of living is going up maybe not
at a huge level but it is going up and
yet
you can't even save to keep up to keep
the value of your
to keep the value of your your dollars
so uh here's the other
and the government controls they and
this has massive perverse effects
because it's not just the
prices go up it's that prices don't
reflect
reality anymore so some prices go up
some prices might not
yeah investments get distorted things
get produced it shouldn't get produced
and then
people like richard wolff turn around
and blame all the distortions and the
perversions
and the crashes and the financial crisis
on capitalism
not on the fact that the fed look at the
financial crisis financial crisis was
caused
you could argue by inflation and and we
could get into that if you wanted but
that's probably a three-hour show just
that
right it was caused by by the federal
reserve and who got blamed for the
financial crisis who would richard wolf
is going to jump up and down
this is a crisis of capitalism this was
caused by capitalism but capitalism is
the negation of the fed
capitalism says there should be no fed
that's that's
item number one on the list of the
things capitalists want is to get rid of
the
of of of uh of the fed and then
grant you guys your wish have
competition for currency and let's see
if bitcoin wins i'm skeptical
but let but i don't care my point is
under freedom i don't care who wins i
just want
free choices and let the best currency
win i doubt that becomes bitcoin
but it doesn't really matter if i'm
wrong let me add to this and and
i think people appreciate and this is a
leftist leftism at its best
that the government and the banks are in
bed with each other this i don't think
is particularly controversial statement
well i
i don't like that statement let me just
say why i don't like it i mean i don't
like it because it assumes that they're
equal partners or that this causality
goes in both directions
from day one and this is really from day
one of the
of the establishment of the united
states banks have been regulated by the
state
and the reason for that is primarily
jefferson and others
founders distrust the financial finance
so from the beginning banks are being
controlled by the state now
over time if i'm if i'm controlling you
you won't have influence over me because
i get to
so yes they get into bed over time but
so i don't like it that they're in bed
together
one is dominating over the other and the
other is participating because what
choice do they
i should explain to you how things work
when you get to bed in bed and it's not
always equal
well okay so okay so let's talk about
safe work
which is very randy and topic she
doesn't like those you read it read the
f i had to read that scene three times
in the fountainhead as i can show you
yeah no because i'm like i looked at the
back cover i'm like a woman wrote this
book in 1943 i must be misunderstanding
yeah she she sure had a lot of shades of
gray yeah
so no she hated that only black and
white
no but um what i meant is 2008
right you have the the bailout of wall
street whereas in 2020 we saw every
medium and small business
under the sun go under there's not even
a pretense that these are going to be
a bailed out so the priorities of the
politicians in my view are always going
to be towards powerful entities
powerful corporations and they're not
going to be about the medium guy the
middle guy
let me just finish my point because i
see you champing at the bit
at the very least if you have regulation
people influencing each other
with bitcoin and with crypto that is not
a possibility
you do not have any agency who is
king of bitcoin who is the federal
reserve of bitcoin
there is no organizing organization or a
management
team now you could say this is a bad
thing but you can't say that this is a
different thing to money as opposed to
federal reserve system yeah so i agree
with that
description of bitcoin my problems with
bitcoin elsewhere um
let me just say about the financial
crisis it's it's
i don't like it phrased that way again
they let lehman go under
um and destroyed lehman brothers in the
past they destroyed uh
uh uh drexel burnham because they didn't
like michael melkin
they are vindictive yes uh it's not an
accident that the
the treasury secretary at the time was
an ex-chairman of
goldman sachs not lehman brothers and
goldman hates lehman and
you know and the next day they bail out
aig
what i what i got out of financial
crisis more than anything and and by the
way there wasn't a bailout so it wasn't
even a bailout
because they gave money to every bank
whether they
had problems or not okay and indeed i
know several bankers
including big banks like jp morgan and
west fargo
and a friend of mine john allison of bbt
who told them explicitly
we don't want your money we don't need
your money we don't and they were
basically a gun was put to their head
and he said
you don't take the money we'll shut you
down basically right the equivalent of
that
um and so they they
they wanted a virtue signal so there's a
big virtual signal we're
we're taking care of things don't worry
we you know we've got everything under
control even though they were completely
panicking
and they had no clue what they were
doing uh one of
one of the things that the financial
crisis really illustrated was
how pathetic ignorant
and incompetent the people at the top
are and they knew it
and they you know supposing goes to
congress says give me 700 billion
don't tell me how to use it because i
have no clue just give it to me
and give me authoritarian power to do it
any way i want and and that was not out
of
a sense of grandeur that was a sense of
panic he had no idea he had no clue
none of them did um they bailed out
everybody they could everybody
under the you know within their
periphery uh when they thought it was
appropriate they were vindictive about
some people like lehman
it was complete arbitrary use of power
it's
the bankers didn't benefit from this
indeed many bankers who took their money
lost from it bank stocks got crushed
after the bailout before the bailout
bank stocks were doing okay
and right after top was announced bank
stocks crushed
because this was bad for banks it wasn't
good for banks
this is just central planning gonna muck
it's it's not
them bailing out elites it's them you
know throwing money at a problem without
knowing
what they would actually do and what the
consequences would be
right but the point is sorry to yep we
agree
the focus will always be on bailing out
elites it's almost but the little bank's
got money too no but i was saying that
last year
there's no talk of saving ice and vice
saving century 21
saving all these other uh industries but
sure they were if you look
it's it's just sure there was if you
look at the if you look at what the fed
did the the the fed was bailing out
third fourth class businesses in all
kinds of
areas that you wouldn't consider elitist
areas uh
the the opportunity the way that's 2008.
yeah no i'm talking about now okay i
talk about covid last year um
what the fed did was unbelievable the
kind of bonds that they were buying
even 2008 even after 2000 i couldn't
believe what they did last year
um ppp the the payable protection
program was targeted everybody everybody
got ppp
um it's not about i don't think it's
about bailing out elites it's about
securing their power base and if they
believe that securing their bowel pace
is wall street then they'll bail out
wall street
they believe securing their power base
is is
writing checks to restaurant owners all
over the country they'll write checks to
restaurant owners all over the country
which is what they did with ppp
um it's all about power for them and
it's whatever will achieve power
whatever will result in power i don't
think it's about elites i don't see
i don't i didn't see elitism in the
bailouts of last year i i i i agree
i agree it wasn't last year i'm saying
that's one distinction between 2008 and
2020 and i do think
just one more thing i do think uh uh
getting in good bed with the elites
is a great mechanism in general for
maintaining one's power oh yeah yeah
that's that's
depending on how are we defined of
course yeah yeah yeah
you mentioned there's some criticism for
towards bitcoin there's a lot of
uh excitement about the technology of
bitcoin for the
the resistance against this kind of
central state pursuit of power that's
part of my criticism because i don't
think it works
so yeah i can imagine a world
i can imagine i'd love to see a
technology evolve
that where money is competitive
and it's it's it's a financial
instrument that the government cannot
touch
you think the state is too powerful and
i think two things i think
i think right now and maybe this won't
be true in the future right
now i think crypto is ill it cannot
function as money right now it just
can't
uh but it does no it doesn't it
functions as a mechanism
it functions as a mechanism to transfer
it's a technology that allows me to
transfer uh fiat money from place to
place but it doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't function because and it can't
because it's too volatile
so i've sold things with bitcoin no i
know you have money but i can sell
things i can buy things and sell things
with my
airline models there are lots of ways in
which you can use things as money
but it doesn't make them money so if
you're using something so let me take
something you
know okay so let me take something you
said before and and it contradicts i
think bitcoin you said
one of the things about money is that
it's stable i know what it's going to
buy tomorrow
right this is why we're against
inflation because i know what
the dollar today i can plan because i
can't plan i don't know what bitcoin is
going to be worth tomorrow
so i can't plan with bitcoin so bitcoin
is way too volatile to serve right now
is money now
the the argument from bitcoin is is yes
it's still being adopted at some point
it'll reach a certain crucial high
profitation yeah yes and then
it will become money because that at
that point it can be used as money
because they don't have a stable
value maybe right now
it's not it's not useful as money
because i can't predict what i can't
invest in in in it knowing what the
value will be
in five years right now it's an asset
it's not a
uh it's not a monetary unit it's it's
much more functions as an asset
assets value can go up i agree function
much more as an asset
as money that's not in disputes i don't
think so i don't think it's money
but so so i think it's it it's still
i think it can compete as a money with
something tangible
so i think in a free market uh some kind
of crypto backed by gold would be more
successful
so bitcoin folks argue that uh
bitcoin has all the same fundamental
properties that does gold
so it's backed by there's a scarcity to
it
and it's backed by proof of work so it's
backed by
you know physical resources and so they
say that it's a very natural replacement
of gold it doesn't need to be connected
to gold
so the two things that gold has that it
doesn't have
um one is gold is not finite gold
gold supply actually grows over time
bitcoin at some point is truly finite
yes at least unless you count the the
fact you can split bitcoins and create
coins but
you know but that's that's a whole other
question right um
so that's one the second is that uh
gold has value beyond its use as a
currency beyond its use as
as as for jewelry and stuff yeah
but but you you minimize that but
jewelry and stuff has been important
for the human race for a hundred
thousand years you can find jewelry
in caves if for the caveman design
jewelry and world of them so we
obviously as human beings value jewelry
a lot
and almost all jewelry evolved to be
made out of gold
because whatever it is within us is
attracted to shiny
shiny gold in particular shiny object
generally so there's something about
gold that appeals to a human being
there's some value that gold has beyond
us being a currency it doesn't
it it's not that bitcoin doesn't now
it's not enough
to use it as money lots of things appeal
to human beings but it
those are two characteristics one that
it's not finite and second that it is
a value beyond that uh that bitcoin
doesn't don't you think the finiteness
could be
framed as a feature the scarcity of
bitcoin no because i think it creates it
creates a real problem with scarcity
economically
it's the it's the issue of planning um
there is a mechanism there's a beautiful
mechanism in markets that
as the supply of gold is is in a sense
the the quantity of gold
is um prices are going down because
there's too little gold right so so the
value of gold in a sense in dollar terms
and so prices are going down
what happens then is you there's a
there's an incentive to then go mine
for more gold right uh because it
becomes cheaper and cheaper than mine
as the price goes down so you mind for
more it it keeps increasing and it keeps
increasing
basically very correlated to the rate of
increasing productivity
that's that's the beauty of gold mining
because it's because
prices are related to gold gold gold is
the dominant money
and it it increases at this about the
same rate as productivity so it keeps
these it keeps prices relatively stable
you still have bouts of inflation and
deflation
but it keeps it relatively stable with
bitcoin it's fine at its ends
now prices will only decline what rate
will they decline at that rate their
decline at the rate of productivity
increases
it's hard to predict what products at
the rate through which productivity
increases for example technological
shocks can
change that dramatically you could get
you could get bouts
of dramatic deflation dramatic price
drops that could
be problematic in terms of planning
the same problem of inflation just
reversed that you had before so
i you know again that it's a technical
issue i'm sure there are ways to get
around it and again i
i'm not sure i don't know if you guys
consider bitcoin the end
or the beginning that is is bitcoin it
or is bitcoin just the first example of
a technology that was evolving i was
just gonna say i don't know
there's same technological issue with
regard to gold which is we now have the
technology that was very expensive
to turn elements into different elements
and a certain
at a certain yeah you could fire
electrons at it or whatever you can make
gold they figure out how to do it it's
not cheap and it's it's
if gold is the standard a lot of
resources are going to be going toward
turning
other things into gold making the
production of gold cheaper and that's
going to have a similar uh consequence
that's kind of the category of security
that bitcoin has talked about that it's
very difficult to do that bitcoin
uh but i would argue that it's
exceptionally difficult to do that with
gold
it is now but the thing is there's not a
huge incentive if gold is
the basis and if gold is worth that much
attack
but gold isn't worth that much gold is
let's say what i'm saying in this world
that we're talking about in the future
in the future yeah
gold is not going to be worth let's say
right now gold is about two thousand
bucks it's less than two thousand let's
say it's two thousand bucks
that's that's its price in terms of all
in dollars so
you'd have to it would have to be worth
your while to create something of 2 000
how much would be willing to put into it
at some point you're right and it's and
at that point i think gold stops being
money right
because they're useless once i can
create it like saying like like silicon
yeah then once i can make out official
gold so i'm just not i don't think
bitcoin is the solution i
i think you know i don't know what the
solution is i wish i i wish i was that
innovative
um but i think i think you need a
solution that has
more of the characteristics of gold than
bitcoin currently has and i'm
i guess i'm surprised at a lot of the
technologists
who view bitcoin as the end game where
it strikes me as it's a it's the birth
of a new tech it represents the birth of
a new technology and who the winner in
that technology is going to be we have
no clue
bitcoin is one of the players there are
other players
there might be a new technology that is
even better than anything we can imagine
right now
that so bitcoin doesn't strike me as
optimal
and that that we should be moving
towards something can you please
stop shilling randcoin for five
minutes yeah it was the you know where
there was rant coin
it was random africa no i was like
currencies
yeah no i mean iran is the south south
african one dollar yeah
iron man coin was i was in china in 20
i think it was 2015 or 14. china china
i was in china 22 something like that
and
this entrepreneur came up to me she said
she's she's
bought this massive quantity of land in
this area in china it's a little
secluded she's starting what she's
calling gold culture
she's serious and she's issuing and she
issued
cryptocurrency based on the land right
back by the land
called rand but iran with a little
portrait of vine
you know a little portrait in the in the
uh in the marketing iron
i don't i don't think it went anywhere
you're not going to be a janitor a
janitor
yeah by the way by the way i do want to
point out something i do enjoy about
objectivists
i constantly talk about ann rand and her
vampire novels i mean
that's the joke you're on thank you uh
and ins
inevitably someone feels they need to
point out that she did not write
vampire novels and her name is actually
ein so thank you thank you
thank you we've been talking about two
hours i own her copy the fountainhead
somehow i thought her name was dan thank
you thank you and it's an anthem
so uh this is really interesting way of
phrasing it which is
i was kidding with the ein i know you
knew you how to pronounce it yeah i know
you know you know
that yeah this got confusing i think we
all know
and we all know that we're jokers we're
all one yeah there's no batman in this
conversation
so it's an interesting way to frame it
is bitcoin the end or
the beginning of something and i've as
sort of with an open mind and seeing
kind of all the possibilities of
technologies out there i also kind of
thought that bitcoin is the beginning of
something but what the bitcoin community
argues
is that bitcoin is the end of the base
layer
meaning all the different innovations
will come
on top of it like for example there's
something called lightning network
where it's basically just like gold is
the end
and everything is built like the
monetary systems like cash and all that
is built on top of gold
uh bitcoin is the end in that other
technologies that build
on top of bitcoin that's that's their
argument and
i get that and i hear that all the time
and i i just i
i don't quite understand that and i and
i think bitcoin has limitations
that potentially other cryptocurrencies
might not have
i you know my attitude towards something
like this is the large extent i don't
understand the technology
uh my views let it play out i
i think i have more fear
of uh physical
the ability of of the government to
crush these things than i think many in
the community
so for example so i i gave a talk uh
bitcoin
you know and they were hyping the
acceptance now a lot of
a lot of vendors are willing to set
bitcoin and this is great i said yeah
it's absolutely great
more options is better than fewer
options but i said you know
that that could be taken away like that
now it's true that we could
exchange bitcoin and the government that
wouldn't know or
i think wouldn't know that we do but
once he's advertising on his website
that he accepts bitcoin or once
he tries to turn his bitcoin into
particular goods
once you manifest it in the physical
world
now the the government can step in so
the government could say you can't sell
anything to anybody using bitcoin
they can do that and you won't be able
to sell it it will be have to go into
the black market so
but that isn't able to sell it just
they're just selling in the black market
yeah but that's where the government
thrives right the government thrives on
letting you do stuff in the black market
so they can decide when to put you in
jail or not right yeah
so so if i'm buying a sweatshirt from
the government
sorry if i'm buying a sweatshirt from
somebody using bitcoin the government
can't monitor
my exchange of bitcoin to him yeah but
they can monitor the
the the sweatshirt being sent to me
right that's where they can interfere
and and i think that at some point to
the extent bitcoin is successful
it will be stopped that is it and and
that's what will stop it from becoming
money
see money can only become money it can
only become money if people are
using it as money right and if the
government can stop it being used
if i can't go to the grocery store and
use my atm
that charges on bitcoin or whatever then
it's not money
and i i think that the government is
going to step in
and stop people from doing that and
that's that's what i
i so i i have more respect and fear for
the
for the power of uh of uh of government
today
i don't see that at all however i could
be wrong and i'm sure jaron hopes he's
wrong
absolutely yeah and i hope the
government just give in and yeah
and the fed tomorrow says yeah let
bitcoin thrive but
i think that one of regulated control
and the only way to regulate and control
it
is is to stop it yeah there's a bunch of
people who argue that bitcoin is too
compelling to argue
to government that they'll actually
embrace it like that it seems government
has positive
meat goals and and wants to do good
things you can ask
no no this is greedy they say government
is greedy because they uh where
bitcoiners have this whole lingo they
say
number go up government is not greedy
governor's
governor is not greedy for money
government is greedy for power power
government is greedy for control
government is much more now
money's good too they'll take the money
if they can get it sure but it's not
fundamentally about money it's
fundamentally and this is something
that liberty many libertarians don't
understand this is something many of the
bitcoin community don't understand
they have far too benevolent of you
of of politicians and the people in
government today by the way
and i know why he's laughing i think i
know why you know exactly nothing
and and we should get to that issue at
some point here
um but uh you know so i so i think
there's a lot of naive
naivete yeah speaking of naivety a lot
of it
you're on no okay i'm not naive i'm i'm
actually providing the warning and all
these bitcoiners
they're saying no no no no no no no one
says i'm naive
naive people think they're not naive
you